guys if you need an accountant check
expresslandon.com they do accountancy
bookkeeping commercial payroll and
secretarial services check them out now
so we're here with brother what's your
name i'm mike
yeah
now
brothers and sisters we just want to
clarify a few things okay i spoke to
mike actually i wanted to speak to mike
the following week yeah
because i really wanted to understand
because i felt as if mike had some sort
of frustration yeah there was something
that he was triggered by and i wanted to
know that now it's easy for me to jump
to assumptions i could come and say you
know what on that day he behaved like
this or i may behave a certain way
towards him as well and i'm just going
to judge him on that i'm going to close
the chapter no i thought let me
understand and that's why if you
remember mike the following when a week
when i came he was trying to
have a go at harton for her rubbish as
well but i said to you can i speak to
you yeah so obviously you were still a
bit maybe upset from the previous week
but tell us from your point of view what
happened that day and maybe some things
that you may want to share to
why he was a little bit hostile
right so i don't know can you hear me
all right yeah yeah yeah so first of all
yeah i want to thank this brother here
right and i call him a brother because
at the end they were brothers
for being a big man for being a humble
guy
just for being himself
and approaching me last week
as he says last week
i had a different mission
and
and really that mission was actually
influenced by the previous week
because
the previous week what happened um
people basically said oh this guy's
anti-muslim is anti-islamic and i say
wait have you not seen me debating with
the christians before so i thought okay
if you haven't seen that i'll come and
show you so that's why i then did i came
out for specifically for hatton who i
actually
i'm just a person that don't like
bullies
and i've seen her do certain things and
i thought now i'm not going to
endorse this
and as i say silence is violence yes i
thought i'm going to just go and i'm
going to
speak even louder than i did when i was
with you
so basically
now he approached me last week so i was
on a different mission and i was still
had lingering
lingering feelings from our previous
interaction
not because of him because i'm not going
to hold anger against him and at the end
of our discussion i shook his hand put
my hand on him like that and for me it
was done
but when i was getting certain feedback
from obviously people
supporting him if you want to put it
like that who were coming at me with
negativity someone said that they would
slap you which i didn't hear no but i
will explain no so people were coming at
me with negativity after that yeah that
made me in a position where although i
spoke with ali last week the second week
yes
i didn't really want to engage yeah so i
give you credit obviously for
approaching me and i'll also agree with
you and be honest that i didn't want to
engage at that time okay i just put my
hands up on that
now in terms of what happened on the day
will explain
number one there was something that
happened
on the day literally minutes before the
video with ali started that was not
included in that video
and there were also things from my
personal life and my experience that
made me
resentful
suspicious
[Music]
and let's say have a low patience
of
i wouldn't even say muslims more like
situations where i see maybe arabs are
picking on
yeah someone from my race yeah so
automatically i was in a position where
i wanted to
i wanted to fight yeah yeah not mean and
then that came and involved itself with
ali which had nothing to do with ali
really but ali was just coming in he
didn't see what happened
and um
and that's what it was so you can ask me
what happened because i've been speaking
for a while i don't know you know what
it is mike yeah what you say i can
relate to you because you know why let
me just take my glasses off so we can
have eye contact
me personally mike
when i since i came to islam there is no
one that has one of muslims i wasn't
born in muslim well in the religion
i always believed in a higher power i
believe always believed in god
but since i came to islam there is no
one that has made me suffer as much as
the muslims
now you might be thinking what do you
mean by that
look
we know we have certain enemies the far
right
some extreme shias not all
ahmedes
zionists um you name it we have a lot of
enemies and i expect from them because
it's your enemy you know what to expect
from the enemy yeah but when you get hit
from the back it hurts more because
you're expecting it from the front when
somebody comes and hits you from the
back it hurts more so to me when it came
to marriage i suffered racism i was
rejected based on not being a specific
culture and these are muslims these are
muslims that are saying no to me and i'm
saying look i'm a muslim as well no but
you're not from our background
so i've been beaten in that way not
literally many times
even in this very park i've been
oppressed by certain muslims yeah who
come here name call um
do variety of other stuff so i have seen
it so i know where you're coming from to
a point where if i if there was any
reason if i was to leave islam it would
never be because of the quran or a
hadith it would be because of muslims
i'll make that very clear it's not a
reason to but we are human beings we're
emotional yeah we're here if you
continuously i'll be honest with you if
i continuously get bullied
by the mexicans i'm going to have be
apprehensive towards mexicans i'm not
going to have tolerance towards mexicans
i have to be real i don't give a damn
allah says in the quran speak the truth
even if it's against yourself or your
kin you know what that means that means
if i know
my friend came and my friend is my
muslim brother let's say and i've spent
i know him for 20 years if i know he's
wronged you i would tell him brother
you're wrong i don't care if i know you
i don't care if you're my muslim brother
i don't give my mom and my family know
you you are wrong
because this is justice and we need to
uphold justice so when you came to me
and when i saw that obviously i didn't
know the full picture and i have to
blame myself because that only i came
shouting as well if you remember yeah i
would say you can i came shouting if you
remember did you get what happened is
this let me just speak quickly um and
there is a video of the entire incident
yes so what happened was la min yes who
i'm going to apologize to as well
because i disrespected him yeah i called
him names yeah
um la min yeah was debating
um another man yeah who's like jamaican
yeah
he was not the most
it was not the
he doesn't speak like you for example
maybe he doesn't even speak like me yeah
he was struggling to actually speak
words let alone to speak his opinion
um he had a bit of a stutter yeah
and what i saw from standing and
watching him it was never my plan to get
involved yeah i didn't come there to oh
i'm yeah oh you saw muslims bullying him
yeah i came yes and there was two black
people yeah surrounded by a number of
people a group of muslims and a lot of
them were arab people i'm just guessing
because they look like arabs
and what i saw
was from me standing in the crowd and
people not knowing
that i was in an arab people thinking
that was one of them yeah we're all one
and the same don't get me wrong yeah but
people i heard people
mocking him yeah so while he's trying to
i mean asked him a question he's trying
to speak they're shouting him down
they're not letting him speak that was
number one
number two
when he started speaking he was
stuttering okay and people started
mocking
like and i'm thinking what is this like
do you understand and then number three
they started mocking his accent
so those three things together
you could see the video i'm like this
like
because i'm not gonna lie
i've i've defended people from all
backgrounds you told me about incident
in i don't want to say where it was
but
listen i don't need to people know me a
lot of muslims know me yeah a lot of a
lot of muslims in london know me i have
muslim family muslim friends when i was
on the street i got like they call me
gangster i got a lot of muslim people
that know me
and they know what i'm like i defend
that's just who i am yeah but
same way you would you would defend a
muslim if they were being bullied same
way you would defend anybody
but especially a muslim if they were
being bullied by by other people yeah
it's the same way unfortunately i cannot
change my skin yeah i am what i am yeah
even if i said oh i am whatever i'm
still going to be what i am yeah so when
i'm there and i'm watching a black man
being bullied and he cannot defend
himself
at some point i'm like this and then the
next minute i didn't even plan it i
don't know what happened yeah i just
stepped in yeah and i straight away i
said listen bro stop you don't need to
keep talking yeah because you basically
people are bullying you you don't need
to keep trying to justify yourself let
the man who is grilling you
justify himself yeah because right now
as far as i'm concerned what i said he's
a black man
performing
for an audience of arabs yeah and he's
bullying another black man that's my
words
so what you then came in at that point
there was a commotion yes and then you
came in not knowing yes what had
happened and you invited me to come over
that's that's definitely your fault
because you could have asked me i'm
sorry what's going on i apologize for
that so from there me and you went into
another discussion we went into another
discussion but that discussion we moved
from
like ah anymore
but inside of me i'm still steaming yeah
yeah i'm still steaming yeah so
physically i'm not angry no more but
psychologically i'm still here yeah so
as soon as we started i just carried on
from where i left off yes but you did
not this is the disconnect you did not
carry on from there yeah yeah yeah you
were on a completely different
wavelength so i had a lot of hostility
i'm not gonna lie hostility in that
moment because i was burning because of
what had happened now why was that
burning because of what happened exactly
like you said i'm not going to go into
details but i've had my experiences of
deep racism yeah
with yeah people
i would say from a specific
yeah and you're probably right region
and that made me have that hostility and
that's what made me in that moment react
the way i did
so i want to apologize to you
i already apologize to you off camera
i want to apologize to ali in front of
everyone four number one coming at him
with hostility that had nothing to do
with him because this guy didn't do
nothing to me
he was the only mistake he made he
didn't ask what was going on so i want
to apologize inside i didn't also come
and shout as well which yeah which may
have left a bad taste in your mouth
about me no no no i ain't even gonna lie
yeah i just i if i have to be honest
yeah i just thought you was their
captain yeah yeah yeah i made an
assumption i made a stereotype i thought
you was it's not even bad it don't
matter where you come from it's not the
point what i'm saying i just thought
these people that were doing that yeah
we're doing that because you're
encouraging that i made a lot of
stereotypes totally made a lot of
stereotypes
so in that moment when we was actually
debating whatever we were having a
conversation i didn't even really want
to debate because i was just like more
like
i was just continuing the argument yeah
yeah so when
at some point
someone you gave me you gave me an
example as to why christianity and
judaism did not come before islam yes
yes yes and then i reacted by saying are
you dumb yeah i said that yeah straight
away someone is like why are you talking
just slap him like yeah i didn't hear
that by the way i didn't if you see the
video you can see the uh
i know you you did it here yeah but you
can see how to correct it yeah i just
want to correct certain things yeah so
that's when you said touch me yeah and
then i was like i was like and i said
the wrong word and i was like don't tell
me that yes
i said that straight away and then i was
like i wish someone would touch you okay
because at that point from when that was
said to me it became a different thing
i'm sorry from that point there was no
more conversation yes yes it became like
i wish someone would touch you yes yes
and then we can just have a party with
it yeah yeah like unfortunately and then
during that i said oh this is my city
obviously listen i'll tell the camera i
don't know jack i don't know nothing in
the city so this ain't my city in that
sense all i mean is if someone's going
to hit me in this consequences i'm not
going to walk away from it that's all i
mean so
without longing it out i just want to
apologize again to ali
i want to apologize to everybody yeah i
apologize to all the muslims for coming
across in that way because that was not
my intention
and as i say i've got muslims in my
family that have spoken to me and they
said look this behavior
is not what we raised you like it's not
what we expect of you yeah right i
explained to them why it happened and
they said look
we know you
and the truth is this happened because
of resentment you develop of what has
happened to you in the past that's sad
though right
and it's true so i just want to
apologize to ali i apologize to
everybody
and uh you know that's all i can say at
the moment mike i apologize as well
because i didn't there you know
sometimes we do come to the park and we
have this like because it's chaos here
no stuff happened we have
pre-assumptions as well we're thinking
okay that person is shouting he must
hate islam and it's not always the case
so i did come shouting back at you when
he was having your first argument which
i do believe left a bad taste in your
mouth before i was the leader et cetera
i'm against that kind of attitude of
taking the mick out of someone because
they're stuttering but anyways look i
really appreciate your humbleness that
you've come and apologized and i
apologize as well if we've wronged you
but i do really relate with the stuff
that you shared with me okay
something quickly
sorry bro
now on the subject of shouting and i
explained because last week there was
another brother
muslim guy that wanted to fight me
because he said i was shouting yeah and
by me shouting i'm being disrespectful
yeah to the muslims
and the way i always go away is i i do
something
or i'm involved in something and then
later on when i calm down yeah yeah i
start to break it down like why did that
guy say that it's not because in the
moment when he said i said come on then
let's let's go for it yeah i was all
but later on it was bugging me i said
why did he actually say that sentence
and i realized
look i speak loud it's how i speak yeah
yeah it's because of my background i'm
nigerian yeah yeah right i'm raised in
nigeria and this is how we communicate
yeah especially if we're having a debate
it's not because
we hate you it's not because we are
aggressive
it's just that we want to show you that
we really believe what we're saying so
as i'm speaking like the brothership
passion the guys why are you shouting so
much you're being disrespectful i'm not
being disrespectful there's no bony in
me that is disrespectful i hate anybody
as soon as i left you it went out the
window in terms of like deep anger
obviously when i started getting threats
or in person online
then that that keeps in me a certain
energy that i am in fighting mode
um but unfortunately it's just something
i want us to be an example to everybody
100 to show 100
you know 100 we lead with love not
exactly we live with love you know just
i will end on this that you know the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him he
said i only came to perfect good
character and this is why i tell you one
of the the biggest enemies to islam are
muslims i always say this and i'll say
again because our attitude and how we
deal with people sadly it causes people
to have resentment i'm not saying all
the time but sadly as muslims the way we
conduct ourselves can be arrogant can be
dismissive can be like in a certain way
where it leaves a base bad taste if i
was not a muslim and i went through what
i went through bro i'll be honest with
you man i would have a bad resentment
towards muslims this is not correct but
it just shows us that how individual all
of us have a responsibility and i'll
just end on that no brothers and sisters
inshallah everybody subhanallah look if
somebody owns up to their mistake that
is a big thing to me i'm trying to say
and we should all learn from that and
with all these defense and this nonsense
whatever it may be we should stop this
kind of attitude and learn from one
another and take this video inshallah as
a reminder for us to fix up because we
have emotional impact on individuals how
we treat them so inshallah that's it my
thank you it's a pleasure we're always
gonna have a relationship i always do
look after yourself um it was a pleasure
man i really really appreciate it and
the brother sisters hope you enjoyed
this video please share it because so
people can now understand the context
what exactly happened why it happened
and we can learn from that inshallah and
we'll probably see more of mike on
salaam corner until next time assalamu
alaikum is
you